so you don't think they uh
pose any threat to the united states
who who in particular the isis or
al-qaeda
i think they pose
a very limited threat to the united
states and i think they pose a greater
threat to the united states today than
they did in 2001. i mean what is
the the last 20 years of war have had
many effects 15 000 u.s military
personnel dead that's that's uniform
personnel and contractors um hundreds of
thousands coming back with ptsd
traumatic brain injuries
uh
the death toll in in the war zones has
been far far worse three to four million
people likely dead in afghanistan iraq
pakistan
yemen
syria
in the part of the war the united states
has been involved in
tens of thousands tens of millions
injured in these war zones and seven
trillion dollars seven trillion dollars
that the united states has spent on
these wars in the last 20 years what
does it produce in addition to all that
death and suffering and what we didn't
spend seven trillion dollars on there
are more militant groups now than there
were in 2001. this war has on its own in
its own terms been a complete and utter
catastrophe and disaster
and i don't i don't think people i mean
we you know we went back to the 70s and
in vietnam i don't think people see the
last 20 years of war in the same way
they saw vietnam as a the disaster that
it was the last 20 years of war has been
at least as disastrous at least as
catastrophic for the united states for
the world as the u.s wars in vietnam and
southeast asia and i think we have to
recognize that because indeed i think
there are greater threats to the united
states today than there were in 2001 but
i think they are still very minimal
we're talking about a small group of
people isis controls almost no territory
now um and al-qaeda is is a
fraction of what it once was
so i think it's really dangerous to over
inflate the problems and to respond to
these problems with war that was the
first mistake the bush administration
made
the attacks of 9 11 took about 3 000
lives
terrible for the people affected for the
families affected absolutely
the united states the bush
administration did not need to respond
to that those crimes with war
by invading a country that had
no i mean the vast majority of people in
afghanistan had no responsibility for
the attacks of 911. the taliban gave
sanctuary to al-qaeda but was not
involved in planning or orchestrating
the attacks of 9 11.
the united states should have responded
to those crimes of
that day september 11 2001 as crimes
responded with criminal justice
responses with criminal justice
agents does that do
how do you do that what
what what does these are people that are
willing to put their lives on the line
to take
to to to
make show your weakness these are people
that you that's a achievement if you do
that to them how are you going to get to
the people that did what they did to to
us
no that's in
indeed i think that the problem was that
by giving them the war they wanted that
was an achievement for them
in the past u.s
governments have responded to terrorist
crimes
as crimes and research shows beyond the
u.s around the world
that responding with warfare
tends not to be a very effective
response to terrorist acts
that responding with diplomacy with
intelligence gathering with criminal
justice responses
is far more effective than war
by giving al-qaeda and osama bin laden a
war it gave them exactly what they
wanted in a much larger platform for
recruiting
for building their movement
and i think the past 20 years shows how
what a disastrous choice that was so if
you like this sort of short club from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]